las olimpiadas de tokio 2020 no
permitirán espectadores extranjeros así
lo anunció el comité olímpico
internacional este sábado una decisión
meditada que pretende evitar un rebrote
del virus en japón durante el evento
deportivo también se anunció que las
cerca de 600.000 entradas olímpicas y
las 30.000 paralímpicas compradas desde
el extranjero serán reembolsadas aunque
los organizadores de los juegos no
especificaron a cuánto ascendería a la
suma de la devolución desde el comité
apelaron a la pandemia mundial del cob y
19 que orinan a carl icahn o thor y
ningún grababa en tren durante las
discusiones hemos comunicado al comité
olímpico y al paralímpico que debido a
la situación con el coronavirus en el
mundo hemos decidido no tener
espectadores internacionales en japón
durante los juegos olímpicos de tokio
2020 y se reembolsarán los tiquetes para
los juegos olímpicos y paralímpicos
comprados por los residentes extranjeros
desde el comité organizador de tokio a
2020 necesita un director para
demolición
la noticia es histórica ya que es la
primera vez que se prohíbe la entrada a
los juegos olímpicos a espectadores
extranjeros en japon los viajes
internacionales siguen restringidos y
las autoridades sanitarias niponas
consideran que permitir la entrada de
asistentes extranjeros al evento
deportivo aumentaría los contagios desde
que los juegos de tokio 2020 fueron
cancelados forzosamente hace un año su
organización ha tenido que ajustarse a
la propagación de nuevas variantes y
rebrotes del virus en japon a pesar de
que el país nipón ya ha puesto en marcha
la vacunación muchos de sus ciudadanos
prefieren el aplazamiento o cancelación
de unas olimpiadas marcadas por la
crisis sanitaria mundial